cancer many of us have lost family
friends or loved ones to this horrible
disease I know that there is something
even in the audience who are cancer
survivors or ones who are fighting
cancer at this moment our heart goes out
to you well this word often conjures up
emotions of sadness and anger and fear I
bring you good news from the frontlines
of cancer research the fact is we are
starting to win the war on cancer in
fact we lie at the intersection of three
of the most exciting developments within
cancer research
the first is cancer genomics the genome
is a composition of all the genetic
information encoded by DNA in an
organism in cancers changes in the DNA
called mutations of what drives these
cancers to go out of control around ten
years ago I was part of the team at
Johns Hopkins that first mapped the
mutations of cancers we did this first
for colorectal breast pancreatic and
brain cancers and since then they have
been over 90 projects in 70 countries
all over the world working to understand
the genetic basis of these diseases
today tens of thousands of cancers are
understood down to exquisite molecular
detail the second revolution is
precision medicine also known as
personalized medicine instead of
one-size-fits-all the methods to be able
to treat cancers there's a whole new
concept drugs that are able to target
cancers based on its unique genetic
profile today there are a host of these
tailor-made drugs called targeted
therapies available to physicians even
today to be able to precise their
therapy for their patients and many
others are in development the third
exciting revolution is immunotherapy and
this is really exciting scientists have
been able to leverage the immune system
in the fight against cancer for example
there's been ways where we find the off
switches of cancer and new drugs have
been able to turn the immune system back
on to be able to fight cancer in
addition there are ways where you can
take away immune cells from the body
train
engineer them put them back into the
body to fight cancer almost sounds like
science fiction doesn't it while I was a
researcher at the National Cancer
Institute I had the privilege of working
with some of the pioneers of the field
and watch the development firsthand it's
been pretty amazing today over 600
clinical trials are open actively
recruiting patients to explore all
aspects in immunotherapy well these
three exciting revolutions are ongoing
unfortunately this was only the
beginning and there are still many many
challenges let me illustrate with a
patient here's a patient with a skin
cancer called melanoma it's horrible the
cancer has gone everywhere however
scientists were able to map the
mutations of his cancer and be able to
give a specific treatment that targets
one of the mutations and the result is
almost miraculous almost tumors seem to
melt away unfortunately this is not the
end of the story a few months later this
picture is taken the tumor has come back
the question is why
the answer is tumor heterogeneity let me
explain
even in the cancer as small as one
centimeter in diameter harbors over a
hundred million different selves
well genetically similar there are small
differences in these different cancers
that make them differently prone to
different drugs so you can need to have
a drug that's highly effective that
kills almost all the cells there is a
chance that there's a small population
that's resistant to the drug so this
ultimately is a population that comes
back and takes over the patient so then
the question is what do we do with this
information
well the key then is to apply all these
exciting advancements in cancer therapy
earlier as soon as we can before these
resistance clones emerge the key to
cancer and curing cancer is early
detection and we intuitively know this
finding cancer early results in better
outcomes and and the numbers show this
as well for example an ovarian cancer if
you detect cancer
in stage 4 only 17% of the woman
survived by 5 years however if you're
able to detect this cancer as early as
stage 1 over 92 percent of women will
survive but the sad fact is only 15% a
woman are detected in stage 1 whereas
the vast majority 17% a woman are
detected in stages 3 and 4 we
desperately need better detection
mechanisms for cancers the current best
boys the screen cancer fall in one of
three categories first is medical
procedures which is like colonoscopy for
colon cancer second is protein mild bio
markers like PSA for prostate cancer or
third imaging techniques such as
mammography for breast cancer medical
procedures are the gold standard
however they are highly invasive and
requires a large infrastructure to
implement protein markers while
effective in some populations are not
very specific in some circumstances
resulting in high numbers of false
positives which then results in
unnecessary work ups and necessary
procedures imaging methods were useful
in some populations exposes patients to
harmful radiation in addition it is not
applicable to all patients for example
mammography has problems in women with
dense breasts so what we need is a
method that is non-invasive that is
lighten infrastructure that is highly
specific that that also does not have
false positives does not use any
radiation and is a Keable to large
populations even more importantly we
need a method to be able to detect
cancers before it's a hundred million
cells in size the such a technology
exists well I wouldn't be up here giving
your talk if it doesn't I'm excited to
tell you about this latest technology
we've developed central to our
technology is a simple blood test the
blood circulatory system will seemingly
mundane it's essential for you to
survive providing oxygen and nutrients
to your cells and removing waste in
carbon dioxide here's a key biological
insight
cancer cells grow and die faster than
normal cells and when they die DNA is
shed into the blood system since we know
the signatures of these cancer cells
from all the different cancer genome
sequencing projects we can look for
those signals in the blood to be able to
detect these cancers early so instead of
waiting for cancers to be large enough
to cause symptoms or for them to be
dense enough to show up on imaging or
for them to be prominent enough to for
you to be able to visualize on medical
procedures we can start looking for
cancers while they're relatively pretty
small by looking for these small amounts
of DNA in the blood so let me tell you
how we do this first like I said we
start off with a simple blood test no
radiation no completely get equipment a
simple blood test then the blood is
shipped to us and what we do is extract
the DNA out of it well your body is
mostly healthy cells most of the DNA
that's detected will be from healthy
cells however there will be a small
amount less than 1% that comes from the
cancer cells then we use molecular
biology methods to be able to enrich
this DNA for areas of the genome which
are known to be associated with cancer
based on the information from the cancer
genomics projects then we're able to
then put this DNA into DNA sequencing
machines and to be able to digitize the
DNA into a C's T's and G's and having
this final readout ultimately we have an
information of more than 5 billion
little billions of letters that output
from this from this run we then apply
statistical and computational methods to
be able to find that the small signal
that's present indicative of the small
amount of cancer DNA in the blood so
this is actually work in patients well
because there's no way of really sort of
predicting right now which patients will
get cancer we use the next best
population cancers and remission
specifically lung cancer lung cancer the
sad fact is even with the best drugs
that we have today most lung cancers
come back the key then is to see whether
we can be able to detect these
karthick cancers earlier than standard
methods we just finished a major trial
with Professor Charles Wharton at the
University University of College London
examining this let me walk you through
an example of one patient here's example
one patient who undergoes surgery at
time point zero and then undergoes
chemotherapy then the patient is under
remission well the he is monitored using
clinical exams and imaging methods
around a four hundred and fifty
unfortunately the candidate can cancer
comes back the question is have are we
able to catch this earlier during this
whole time
we'd be collecting blood serially to be
able to measure the amount of CT DNA in
the blood so the initial time point as
expected there's a high level of cancer
DNA in the blood however this goes away
to zero in subsequent time points and
remains negligible
after a subsequent point however around
840 we see the rise of cancer DNA in the
blood and eventually it goes up higher
for days 400 and 450 here's the key if
you've missed it at days 340 we see the
rise and the cancer DNA in the blood
that means we are catching this cancer
over a hundred days earlier than
traditional methods this is a hundred
days earlier where you can give
therapies a hundred days earlier where
you can do surgical interventions or
even a hundred days less for the cancer
to grow or 100 days less for resistance
to occur for some patients this hundred
days means the matter of life and death
we're really excited about this
information so because of this
appointment we've done additional
studies now in another cancers including
breast cancer lung cancer and ovarian
cancer and I can't wait till to see how
much earlier we can find these cancers
ultimately I have a dream a dream of two
vows of blood that in the future as part
of all of our standard physical exams
we'll have two vials of blood drawn
and from the two boughs of blood we will
be able to compare the DNA from all
known signatures of cancer and hopefully
then detecting cancers months to even
years earlier even with the therapies
that we have currently this could mean
that millions of lives could be saved
and if you add on to that recent
amendments and immunotherapy and
targeted therapies the end of cancer is
in sight the next time when you hear the
word cancer I want you to answer the
emotions hope hold on cancer researchers
all around the world are working
feverishly to beat this disease and
tremendous progress is being made this
is the beginning of the end we will win
the war on cancer and to me this is
amazing news thank you
[Applause]